Please welcome Marlee Matlin, Troy Kotsur,
and their interpreters, Jack and Justin.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
(Drew squeals)
Oh, Jack, I'm so happy to see you.
Hello, nice to meet you.
Jack and I have known each other for-
And Marlee.
And Marlee, obviously.
Actually, Marlee, how long have we known each other?
Well, we've known each other really a long time.
A long time probably than we actually realize.
Do you remember how we met?
Do you remember when we met?
Yes, yes.
You do?
Actually, let me tell you, let me tell the story.
Yes, okay, go.
Ready, ready?
Okay, here we go.
So we were in the, it was a bar,
it was called the Columbus Bar and Grill,
and it was the night of this crazy award ceremony
that we went to with my old boyfriend who won that night.
And William Hurt, Michael Douglas, Raúl Juliá.
Yes, I knew it!
Yes.
And so we got into the bar, it was like one in the morning,
and I was a little bit sort of buzzed, but anyway,
more than necessary really,
and we walked in and we sat down,
and someone comes up and says, "Hi, welcome.
What would you like to drink?"
And I looked, I was like, "What?
ET?"
No, I was so thrown.
It was you, all of you, this big, this big.
And William hurt flipped out when he saw you
because you guys did a movie together.
Oh my gosh, so he played-
So mad.
He was mad.
That's right.
Did he hold me up?
Yeah, I think he did.
Yes.
You were this much.
Yeah.
Because I played his daughter in "Altered States."
I know.
And yes, he treated me like his daughter, that's right.
I remember that, yeah.
He was mad at me and he held me up.
Yeah.
It was a very interesting journey since then.
It's been an interesting journey since then.
But since that moment, I remember many times
and many years feeling very comfortable and safe with you.
Me too.
The world wasn't always so comfortable and safe.
I know, I know.
But when I was with you.
Yeah.
I appreciate that you said that.
And I was so excited to see you.
Thank you.
And I love this film so much.
And Troy, first of all, your performance is so beautiful.
And I loved that you had watched Marlee
win the Oscar for Best Actress.
Is that in 1987?
5 years ago.
Yeah, exactly.
Around that time, I was a senior in high school.
So you can do the math and figure out what my age was.
35 years ago, 35 years ago.
What she said.
It was the first time I saw authentic deaf representation
on screen in "Children of a Lesser God."
It really inspired me and I felt connected.
And it really gave me hope as an actor to pursue acting.
And so I continued for many years as an actor
and it led me to get to this point.
And it's been truly amazing to finally work with Marlee.
She's just a foot away from me right now.
And I never thought that would happen.
(audience applauding)
And you have that chemistry.
And Troy, you're making history now yourself
as being the first deaf actor to be nominated.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, love you all.
When you see this film, this is a no-brainer,
but how is the full circle moment being next to Marlee,
who inspired you back then?
Well, it was such an interesting timeline for me.
So Marlee was very young, won the award,
and I was inspired, and I remained true to my vision.
I was patient with all of the frustration and politics
and oppression and all that.
And finally reached this point, looking at her,
I finally feel like we understand each other.
We are able to share this journey
and this experience together and help each other out
and help Hollywood to begin to improve opening their minds,
to begin thinking outside the box
and all those types of things,
because the deaf community has so many stories to tell.
You know, for Troy, I think knowing,
after 35 years since I won the Oscar,
and I've seen so much and I've plowed through all the-
I mean, it's been an interesting journey.
Really, a wonderful one, but at the same time,
compared to what might have happened in the past up to now,
I think now more eyes are open, more ears are open,
more people are aware of our community, of our culture,
our beautiful language, American Sign Language,
and there's a lot more opportunities.
And yet, there's still more work to do.
But one thing I've been seeing is
there is more collaboration.
There are deaf actors, directors, writers,
who are working with those of us in the business
who happen to be working with us.
So we're collaborating.
And I think collaboration is the key these days.
(upbeat music)